something we don't want to speed through
this year's crop of celeb Super Bowl
commercials
[Music]
need our own Supply
and we're gonna have a big presence
yeah it feels very very surreal Aaron
for Breaking Bad scenes
[Music]
that to my ear sounds distinctly like
flooding yes yes
other Throwbacks clueless you got the
Plaid suit the closet the white Jeep and
the debate as if I was like as if
whatever former co-star Paul Rudd a
Kansas City Chiefs fan suits up as
Ant-Man Don't Judge Me Anton
I'll call free I'll be so nervous
watching that game that I'm not even
gonna I can't even think about that uh
but it was yeah pretty pretty exciting
amen come back let's go to Studio man I
gotta do me missing Jack Harlow quits
rapping and becomes a triangle player in
this Doritos ad that has a surprise
appearance from Elton John and Missy
Elliott my mom was playing me Missy when
I was super young she's one of my
biggest influences meeting her was a
huge moment for me I'm gonna eat you
guys things take a tasty turn for Jack's
bestie Pete Davidson when he finds a
pint-sized Brie Larson and Jon Hamm in
his fridge in this Hellman spot he
really is everywhere our pick for best
on-screen Feud Steve Martin and Ben
Stiller who roast each other for Pepsi
banjo player Nepal baby who's the new
guy
I don't know
what he's rock star which one of you
wants a piercing Ozzy Osbourne who just
announced his retirement from touring
gets a desk job for work day Anna Faris
fares all for avocados from Mexico and
in this Oikos ad Deion Sanders faces off
against his family that's his son shadur
who's dating Euphoria star storm Reed
Melissa McCarthy Meghan Trainor and
multiple Adam drivers will also get
airtime what's it been like acting
opposite Adam Driver you know I honestly
it's exciting and see how many stars you
can spot in Michelob ultra's Ode to
Caddyshack there successions Brian Cox
Tony Romo and Serena Williams beat the
ball it's really all about joy and you
know me off camera and I always like to
mine
[Music]